bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors le variant
omicron annoncé comme le nouvel ennemi
un peu partout en europe est ce
qu'aujourd'hui la situation est hors de
contrôle selon vous
bonjour
je pense qu'il a des pays d'europe
qu'ils sont plus touchés que d'autres
par cette variante entretien considère
la gaieté côté européen outre excite les
bâches m'emprisonnent bactec et depuis
par exemple du sud
en italie en espagne en année on a les
primes ont détecté deux premiers cas dès
la 21 e tron mais qui reste très confiné
effectivement menayas itou la polémique
qui concerne la vaccination les faits d
avoir la troisième dose qui protégeait
la plus je pense que de ce côté là on a
la preuve de l'échec est là au niveau
global de vaccination
ici dans les pays
développés on parle troisième dose de
mystère vous voulez l'appeler alors
qu'emma tout le continent africain'' où
les gens nommés bac c'était la première
doivent donc on continue voire une
politique poreuse par rapport à
l'évolution des miros pour ce qui est
spécial et alien par contre ici les taux
de remplissage des restes bas on a 10%
du taux de remplissage effectivement la
plupart des patients qui atterrit en
réaction des patients qui ne sont pas
vaccinés mais si certains j'ai avec les
commodités la varenne au micro ondes il
commence à toucher les prêts sont plus
jeunes mais forcément celle là celle ci
qui n'étaient pas vaccinés ont été
vaccinées tardivement
ce que je trouve étonnant c'est la
surprise tient à cela s'est terminé
alors que moi je n'ai pas
et puis des meilleurs gobillot l'homme
est forcément penser les comportements
des virus et il fallait bien s'attendre
c'est qu'ils me doivent tous les justes
noir les taux de vaccination en caisse
qui permettait qui permettait d or noir
arrêté à la réglisse âge derrière pour
ceux qui luttent ali simplement c'est le
cas par rapport à un 1er mai mais
dernière on ne te les monts plissage est
beaucoup plus beau des rénovations et
iront à chad j'ai rapidement 7e italie
on a globalement 14% de la population
en dessous de 12 ans qui est vacciné au
mode avec des doses alors omicron qui
est pour l'instant plus contagieux mais
moins dangereux vous venez de le dire
peut-être que les réalisations les
services de réanimation sont remplis en
italie dans d'autres pays également
d'europe
on le voit ces derniers ces derniers
jours des des mesures sanitaires
beaucoup plus strictes qui ont été
imposées au royaume uni au danemark
l'allemagne aussi qui a décidé
2 voilà de faire une liste de pays qui
sont jugées à haut risque avec des
quarantaines qui vont être mises en
place c'est ce que finalement
aujourd'hui toutes ces séries de mesures
qui sont prises par les différents états
sont suffisantes vraiment pour on va
dire pas pour pour endiguer d'une
certaine manière voilà les les risques
de contagion
effectivement on retrouve un peu
d'amateurisme ce qu'il a comme vous
dites plier à certaines doses échappe
pas j'ai l'impression que les hommes
politiques bon format l'écran je dis
halte au départ inconditionnel du virus
et du court mais on a tâtonné
depuis toujours cannes et les mines
aujourd'hui on a la sienne sans corps
médical qui est plus développée mais
toujours comme des nouveautés dans la
partie des découvertes qui n'était fait
on a mis en route campagne vaccinale
effectivement avec des vaccins qui
sauvent expérimental ski et les études
ils ont été très applaudis par rapport à
une moyenne mons et de les mépriser
moyens économiques et les moyens
matériels humains pour un effort très
important sur des études mais forcément
le temps où il habitait comprenez et
effectivement si on prix de l'action ces
révisions c'est un conseil on s'est
rendu compte dans la campagne vaccinale
ce qui marche qui ne marche pas
souvenez-vous à castres à peine quatre
départs et et max est très utilisé et a
fait l'usure ans accord qu'ils vérifient
ce risque la couverture vaccinale est il
n'était pas le meilleur à utiliser
aujourd'hui ça pose des problèmes on a
des vaccins qui couvrent mais qui
couvrent relativement 100 microns et
nancy mais il faut les prochains mois
pour découvrir ce qui va se passer et ce
qu'il trouve inquiétant le cyclone a pas
de politique l'europe et cinq rafale et
celle d'europe et aussi les messages
qu'ils étaient très bien passé s'est
fait vacciner sa sortie et j'ai commencé
à l'oublier tous les gestes d'hygiène
qui permet quand même d'éradiquer les
pandémies on avait vu l'année dernière
avec très attention pendant une période
de grande qualité grippe là axel des
hypothèses voilà ce que moi j'ai une
copine qui était récemment en angleterre
c'est une collègue ils étaient étonnés
qui dans le métro et dans les transports
publics tout le monde était ce un masque
donc vous voyez il ya quand même des
règles minimum en sait aujourd'hui qui
porte un masque et en des lieux est
clos où
la proximité avec les autres blessés les
personnes portant des masques et protège
face à l'anglais j'ai trouvé encore un
fois j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont fait
un peu d'amateurisme et surtout en
europe et des sites et ensembles et
mittal imminent en impose aux gens qu'il
ya une des autres pays une tests même
vacciné voyez notre pays pose la
quarantaine rien n'est si vous
connaissez pas d'harmonie européenne de
coordination à l'échelle de l'europe
pourtant voilà les les
les 27 dirigeants de l'ue s'étaient
réunis récemment à bruxelles pour
essayer justement de de trouver une
certaine union ensemble pour faire face
au co vis de vous parler de la
vaccination on sait qu'en europe voilà
la vaccination a atteint un bon niveau
en tout cas les gens vont se faire
vacciner en afrique là les douze manque
est ce que finalement on va se retrouver
dans le même cas de figure tout voilà
peut-être tous les ans avec un nouveau
variant qui va émerger parce que
justement certains pays africains les
plus pauvres même n'ont pas reçu de
vaccin
ça c'est fort probable et comme je
disais je suis pas un expert dé santé
publique or espère des maladies
infectieuses mais on sait très bien qu
ici on est dans un monde corus est en
voyage ils sont très rapides donc on
sait très bien aujourd'hui qui si on
n'arrive pas à avoir une politique
mondiale uniforme qui fila se passait il
ya des pays où incapable vaccinale n'a
pas été fait forcément ils vont
développer dédaignant et ensuite ces
derniers arrivent dans des pays où les
taux de vaccination est très fort mais
très très maxi d'orient qui sont on nous
a sélectionné par les vaccinés ils vont
sans durcir et devenir plus virulent à
skis en tout cas il ya un an alors qui
va être sélectionné de la vaccination
service à ses objectifs donc je trouve
qu'on n'est même pas capable d'avoir
réponse uniforme au niveau européen est
encore loin que l'on rogne annoncé
demande qu'est ce qui sert le msc bon
sinon c'est quoi vraiment là le
l'intérêt global et même pour convaincre
les gens à se vacciner nancy s'est il y
a voyez il ya tout le temps des
discours de nos politiques qui sont
claires à ce moment là c'est les accès
étaient vraiment très utile il faut
avoir le courage d'imposer la
vaccination comme obligatoire n'est pas
laisser cette histoire c'est celle de
liberté mais avec des contraintes sous
la liberté perso voyez je trouve qu'ils
ont mal de clarté est vraiment des
politiques qui prennent les bonnes
décisions et qu'ils ont le courage de
les imposer merci beaucoup en tout cas
ouverte aux à giovanni d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
un médecin chirurgien en italie